hello i'm jordan slansky associate  producer at Conan is you're probably  already aware Conan O'Brien and I have  shared many fantastic life enriching  experiences together be honest with me  do you have friends name one person you  man this was the cover of douche weekly  Thank You major face I derive great  pleasure from attending this convention  in San Diego I invited Conan to attend  with me this year but he declined  instead he gave me this special badge  that will hopefully give me some  exclusive access let's see what it gets  me  [Music]  [Music]  thanks going just okay is not okay when  it comes to Conan Kahn or your wireless  network  [Music]